I wish you health shanov Ukraine Ukrainian women
immediately good news Same such news mi
us check SD vdalosya zni z royko full
207 ukrainv 180 privates and sergeant 27
officer mayzhe half of the zakhinniki of
Mariupol stench of the armored forces of the national guard of the state
border service and
nationally for 207 lops will soon be
home z r  207 Rodin was already happy singing the
clap of the telephone home already sensed
the most important words I am happy, what is
going on in the same
exchange for an hour on a large scale viiny
zagalom
335 people went away I turned and froze
everything to turn the skin and the skin we
didn’t forget about anyone according to the skin call shukae
yes yes yes I am I am already in Ukraine they
changed me Yes I am already in Ukraine everything I am
living yes yes I am alive everything is fine with me
na Swa
[music]
Sla were very
pleased we were waiting, it’s just that I don’t
know
that I have never had such feelings  it was and
right here is our own land, our homeland is here, it’s
very good, my daughter was born
today on January 31, they finally exchanged
returned home
and a week ago they tried to exchange too, but the
exchange did not
take place, they returned now we are
happy We hope to get home quickly
Hello Mom it’s me Yes yes yes
us  exchanged today, in short,
we are already in Russia Yes, just
how are you
doing?